[Musique]
bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour un
nouveau numéro de dimanche en politique
nous allons nous pencher aujourd'hui sur
la nouvelle donne de l'élection
présidentielle avec françois fillon
candidat de la droite un président qui
renonce une primaire embouteillée des
francs tireurs à gauche sur ce plateau
pour les républicains valérie grandet
bonjour bonjour ligne métier pendant la
primaire de droite la référente de
françois fillon en côte-d'or bonjour eni
rebeyrotte
bonjour vous êtes le maire divers gauche
d'autun saône-et-loire très proche du ps
et vous êtes signataire du groupe movida
qui tente de réfléchir à l'avenir de la
gauche julien houle bonjour bonjour vous
êtes dans l'yonne le secrétaire
départemental du front national est par
ailleurs conseiller régional de
bourgogne franche comté et alexandre
emorine bonjour bonjour vous êtes dans
cette campagne pour la france a soumis
ce de jean-luc mélenchon
j'ai évoqué plusieurs points pour
commencer ce nouveau paysage mais la
nouveauté est une première sous la vème
république c'est un président qui ne se
représente pas alors est-ce que c'est
l'homme vaincu par son parti c'est
l'homme vaincu par les conséquences
d'une primaire qui l'a obligé à un
certain nombre d'alliances ou c'est
l'homme qui est vaincue par une
cinquième république qui dévore ses
présidents ckoi rémy rebeyrotte
écoutez c'est une très bonne question
que vous posez la mosquée sur cet
avantage de quelqu'un qui n'a pas réussi
ce qui est sûr c'est que je ne suis pas
moins chaud partisan des primaires c'est
un mécanisme j'allais dire comme un
autre c'est un moyen et ce n'est pas une
fin en soi et que sans doute que la
primaire qui avait permis à françois
hollande un moment donné de de trouver
un élan dans la campagne de 2012 l'a
vraisemblablement lui a posé quelques
difficultés notamment un statut qui
prévoit que le candidat en exercice se
présente à une primaire ça me semble un
peu compliqué à gérer votre vision et au
delà de la primaire elle est au delà
mais déjà je partage tout à fait cette
idée de primaire qui est totalement
contraire à nos institutions
premièrement puisque l'aca laisse la
part belle au parti alors que l'élection
présidentielle c'est un homme ou une
femme l'occurrence qui va au devant du
peuple français
on l'a vu que ces primaires enfin
du moins à droite a été une querelle
d'ego de revanchards une bataille pour
les places
et puis là je dirais clé les positions
vont se vont s'étoffer pour les postes
de ministre avec les fillonnistes les
sarkozystes les juppéiste haut à gauche
c'est le cafouillage total donc c'est
vrai que pendant cette période ça fait
six mois qu'on parle des primaires ça
fait six mois qu'on ne parle pas des
français de leurs préoccupations et de
leur avenir et sur françois hollande
jeudi justin lin il a été vaincu déjà
par lui-même par son bilan calamiteux
par une méthode de gouvernement
et il a été vaincu aussi je pense par
par marine le pen c'est à dire que le
fait que nos idées progressent le fait
qu'elle soit donnée au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle l'a sans doute
dissuader de se présenter
évidemment puisque moi françois fillon
c'est lui qui a obtenu de haute lutte le
maintien de cette primaire à droite et
moi je trouve que c'est un gage de
modernité
cette primaire en effet dans nos dents
on va dire dans la les valeur
intrinsèque de la droite première fois
qu'on faisait une primaire on savait pas
bien quelles étaient les personnes qui
allaient s'y intéresser et en fait ça a
été un vrai succès puisque plus de 4
millions de français qui se déplacent
pour voter à cette primaire
aujourd'hui dire que ça ne serait pas
possible ça serait aussi dire aux
français bat finalement vous n'avez pas
votre place pour choisir votre candidat
et on en a prouvé le contraire
alexandre emorine je reviens sur
françois hollande
jean luc mélenchon il a soutenu françois
hollande au deuxième tour de
présidentielle
cinq ans la vie à bat nicolas soir il a
appelé à battre on n'allait pas on
n'allait pas quand même appelé cinq ans
après cinq ans après votre analyse sur
le fait que françois hollande ne se
représente pas c'est quoi c'est dû à sa
trahison et dès le début si vous voulez
nous dès le début de ce quinquennat on a
alerté en dix ans la politique qui est
menée elle va dans le mur et les
mauvaises
il faut faire autre chose trahison des
électeurs de jean luc mélenchon
peut-être mais pas forcément des
électeurs de françois hollande
binationaux en france françois hollande
avait déclaré qu'ils allaient combattre
le monde de la finance qu'il allait
s'attaquer à la question des lobbys au
final il n'en a rien été
le lendemain de son élection est allé
signer le traité qui avait été rédigé
par mu sarkozy avec madame merkel c'est
ça qui s'est passé concrètement pour les
gens donc nous si vous voulez on peut
pas donc
déjà on constate que donc les trahisons
n'ont fait que françois hollande ne peut
pas légitimement sur présente
aujourd'hui ne peut pas participer pour
rebondir sur le sujet des primaires on
peut pas participer à cette heure à
cette mascarade à un congrès du parti
socialiste aujourd'hui parce que
participent à une primaire ce serait en
accepter les règles
ce serait soutenir le vainqueur quel
qu'il soit et si demain le vainqueur et
manuel valls qui est le tenant est
l'exécutant la politique de françois
hollande on peut pas décemment nous dire
allez-y voté pour manuel valls vainqueur
et arnaud montebourg
c'est ce qu'il espérait mais monsieur
montebourg a peut-être quelques
propositions qui peuvent être assez
intéressante sur les questions sociales
notamment un mais par contre
l'indifférence de fond c'est que nous on
n'est pas là pour réformer la vème
république pour l'amender on est là pour
une sixième république pour que les
citoyens il a reparlé d'affidés de
république arnaud montebourg je rappelle
qu'il est l'acteur jean luc mélenchon
par les 6e république de 6ème république
pardon depuis les années 90 mais nous on
va là donc la 6ème république vernon
montebourg elle est peut-être décidé par
le ou non veut que soient les citoyens
qui la fasse tout simplement
c'est ça la différence à elle peut avoir
mais si monsieur montebourg veut
diffuser nos idées dans la société
travaille pour une finale tendue
on voulait réagir venir moi je videmment
je partage pas même point de vue sur le
bilan du championnat moins qu'on puisse
dire
je pense par contre je je je je
conseille à la droite de ne pas mettre
dans ses statuts que le futur président
si jamais celle qu'à soi dans une future
primaire en 2022 ou quelque chose comme
ça c'est à dire que si vous voulez ça
pose un véritable problème les merdes
les générations y compris j'allais dire
ce qu'on a vécu dans le quinquennat avec
l'organisation des frondeurs qui était
déjà à ce moment là dans la future
primaire de gauche que nous allons vivre
voilà mon premier élément deuxième
élément je ne fais pas partie comme vous
du du front du repli ce qu'elle appelle
le front du repli qui disent aux
français vous savez faut pas aborder la
mondialisation il faut se replier
protectionnistes pour les un repli sur
les valeurs pour les autres replis
identitaires pour chacun moi je ne suis
qu'un racket je ne suis fan
suis pas du tout dans cette dans cette
logique là je pense que le discours de
vérité c'est de dire qu'il faut préparer
ce pays
bien sûr protéger les plus fragiles pas
soutenir les rentes de situation et
préparer ce pays à rentrer pleinement
enfin la mondialisation et dans le
quinquennat il ya eu des choses très
positives de ce point de vue là on voit
j'allais garder des éléments clés ont
été faits alors sans doute
insuffisamment sans doute d'ailleurs je
le dis mes regrets par rapport à
françois hollande
je regrette le ça va mieux parce que
quand on est dans une situation comme
cela est une situation de mutation c'est
un discours de combat condate qu'on doit
tenir et pas le discours du savagnin
pour le reste je pense qu'effectivement
il faut affronter les difficultés et non
pas ce repli hier en disant c'est trop
dur replions nous revenons à l'autarcie
au protectionnisme et surtout faisons en
sorte que le pays n'entre pas dans la
mondialisation moi je voulais qu'on
revienne sur notre point de départ c'est
la nouvelle gré et dans la nouvelle
donne alors ce en plein deuil partis
politiques noël donne il y à l'élection
françois fillon dans la primaire dont un
certain nombre d'observateurs font
remarquer qu' on va dire que ça
positionne la droite à droite
est ce que ça veut dire je n'ai redoules
que ça nous désavantage au front
national parce qu'une partie des
électeurs de la droite ne nieront pas
chez marine le pen non pas du tout je
vais juste répondre sur le ça va mieux
moi ce que je regrette c'est les 6
millions de chômeurs ce que je regrette
c'est les 9 millions de pauvres
notre pays ce que je regrette c'est les
15 millions de français qui souffrent
crédit logement tout ça tout ça c'est
les échecs là tous et les échecs du
patient elles sont là et c'est la pâte
entre françois hollande et manuel valls
estimé de nicolas sarkozy et de sa
doublure françois fillon mais sur ce que
vous me disiez françois fillon n'est pas
un candidat de droite françois fillon
c'est le candidat de l'ump c'est le jir
et que c'est pas tout à fait la gauche
la réforme de la sécurité sociale 500
mille fonctionnaires en moins c'est pas
franchement françois fillon fait une
espèce monsieur fillon s'il m'a demandé
si je faisais une espèce de
id qui n'ont entre un monstre antisocial
donc vous dis-je et la suppression de
500 mille fonctionnaires ou didier
également donc qu'il veut des rembourser
les frais d'optique ses meetings il
s'attaque même aux personnes handicapées
puisqu'il a c'était mercredi dernier x
était une absurdité de consacrer donc
des logements donc aux personnes indique
handicapées en france ce qui est
totalement aberrant mais d'un autre côté
il se fait passer pour un candidat de
droite avec des propositions fermes et
radicale alors qui se s'est couché
totalement devant l'islamisme devant le
communautarisme
il a dit qu'il accueillerait des
migrants s'il était maire il est pour la
répartition des immigrés clandestins ce
dans toutes les communes il est pour la
construction de minarets
il a adapté il a adapté en 2004 des
examens du bac au calendrier islamique
donc tout ça en fait montre que c'est
une escroquerie et qui laissait les
grands commis de ferme
notez d'ailleurs franchement je me
demande qui doit parler de caries je
crois qu'en fait ce qui embête tout le
monde sait que françois fillon il a
tracé son sillon
il a un vrai cap pour la france et il
dit la vérité aux français
donc ça ça embête beaucoup de monde
aujourd'hui parce que en fait il a fait
un diagnostic de la france qui est très
précis et pourquoi parce que pendant des
mois et des mois il a rencontré des
français des vrais français dans la
ruralité dans les villes et jeff au
medef dans les banques d'émission
européen a montré des syndicalistes il a
rencontré des choix de la positionnement
qui le situe quand même plutôt sur la
droite de l'échiquier de la droite que
est à la jupe est qu'ici que bientôt la
droite réactionnaire nombreux soucis
réformatrice si on regarde bien le
programme de françois fillon on veut
aller en profondeur et réformer ce pays
en effet pour aborder tous les to les
des enjeux majeurs auxquels l'afrique
est confrontée le dos alors c'est à dire
l'emploi la lutte contre les injustices
et sociales et économiques dont alors là
je pense
et alors et alors
de dire que françois fillon il a été le
premier à dire qu'il fallait vraiment se
donner les moyens pour vaincre ce
totalitarisme islamique
je trouve un dans les faits mais il est
blessé il a des troupes dans les faits
c'est le laxisme et la complaisance va
regarder
il a été le premier ministre de nicolas
sarkozy a validé l'intervention en libye
qui installe et les islamistes en libye
il a inauguré la grande mosquée
d'argenteuil en 2010 les gens disaient
qu'ils avaient passé la mosquée rassoul
23 tennis celui qui rejette le plus
l'islam enfin nous on est on je vous le
dis franchement on arrivait dans ce pays
remonte pour rebondir avec pour vous
faire nous faire avancer mais vous mais
aussi parce qu'on peut encore m'a fait
quelque chose je voulais je voulais pour
vous faire avancer faire remarquer
quelque chose qui est que vous vous êtes
positionner rapidement sur le terrain du
social
julien ou double en parlant des
personnes âgées des handicapés est ce
que ça signifie que le front national va
devoir quitter d'une certaine partie son
positionnement à droite est allé sur le
terrain du social sur lequel vous allez
être en affrontements entre jean luc
mélenchon et marine le pen sur ce
terrain là pour moi je vais revenir tout
simplement sur les propositions de
monsieur fillon on est aujourd'hui dans
une situation vous avez un agriculteur
qui suscite tous les deux jours vous
avez des policiers qui n'en peuvent plus
des personnels hospitaliers qui sont à
bout et la solution de monsieur fillon
ce serait de supprimer 500 mille emplois
publics d'augmenter la tva est supprimée
lisf c'est ça la solution magique
aujourd'hui je suis désolé la logique de
françois fillon
c'est la logique de france hollande
puissance 10 c'est ça qu'il faut c'est
ça qu'il faut constater aujourd'hui je
suis désolé ce que veut françois fillon
aujourd'hui c'est vrai cela ne s'est pas
senti un accessoire voilà ce que ce que
veut françois fillon aujourd'hui c'est
détruire l'état celle inverse de celle
inverse de ce qu il faut faire
aujourd'hui faut renforcer l'état les
gens ils n'en peuvent plus dans les
quartiers dans les campagnes vous avez
plus un service public aujourd'hui et
renforcer l'état aujourd'hui c'est
renforcer les territoires c'est ça qu'il
faut aujourd'hui j'ai pas le détruire le
moyen donner des moyens aux personnes
qui sont sur le terrain
donner des moyens aux policiers des
voitures d'essai ce monsieur fillon que
j'apprenne j'ai dit
12000 postes de policiers sous quand
sous le mandat de monsieur sarkozy n'a
que fillon à ma propose de revenir
hausse effective de 2007 au minimum on a
besoin d'une sécurité aujourd'hui on a
besoin d'une sûreté publique pour les
jolies mais c'est pas le nombre de
personnes qui feront que la sécurité
sera le mieux la mieux gardée en france
à dire ça aux policiers les moments il
est actif mais à les voir aller les
rencontrer dans l'économie arias ou les
façons la façon dont aujourd'hui ils ont
les moyens ils n'ont plus de moyens pour
faire leur travail ainsi donc donnons
déjà des moyens supplémentaires mais
supprime encore le dépense publique
parce que c'est parce qu'ils réclament
les policiers forcément plus de monde
sur le terrain c'est qu'on leur donne
des moyens qu'on leur donne des outils
pour faire leur travail
ça nous amène à je fais deux suivantes
que cette émission c'était la question
qu'est ce qui va se passer dans cette
campagne sur quoi va se jouer finalement
cette campagne vous avez commencé
service public ou pas dépenses publiques
ou pas europe ou pas il y avait un
sondage bva dans lequel on posait la
question français sur les sujets qu un
pacte et les intentions de vote en gros
c'était chômage 87% sécurité 80% et on a
l'impression en même temps que c'est pas
forcément en réalité là dessus que ça va
se jouer de votre point de vue rémy
rebeyrotte c'est quoi le l'enjeu de
cette campagne c'est le chômage c'est
c'est revenir en arrière sur des choses
qui ont été faites ou c'est peut-être
des idées nouvelles on pense par exemple
au revenu universel ou des choses comme
ça que certains ont envie d'amener dans
le débat c'est de mon point de vue c'est
surtout un choix entre le repli sous
toutes ses formes où la confrontation
par rapport aux mutations et donc c'est
vrai qu'il faut continuer à préserver et
à protéger les plus fragiles
ça c'est une évidence pas parcours
protéger les rentes de situation et nous
en avons encore de part et d'autre dans
notre pays
rentrer pleinement dans la
mondialisation je le disais des échanges
ce n'est pas un choix soutenir
l'entreprise et ça a été fait quand même
sous le mandat lors peut-être faut-il en
revoir les formes mais soutenir
l'entreprise et celui qui investit ne
pas être dans la logique du statu quo
s'ouvrir au monde
s'ouvrir au monde et aux autres cultures
c'est un élément absolument plus
dans le monde où nous sommes confrontés
aujourd'hui parce qu'il sélection et
denis robert est en europe et dans le
monde
oui mais on en sort plus vivant mais je
crois pas si vous voulez que il faille
est dans la logique du consommateur
c'est à dire servir à nos concitoyens
le discours qu'il voudrait qu'on leur
serve je pense que cette nuit macro hier
aujourd'hui la logique
la logique c'est la citoyenneté cela
l'appel à la responsabilité des citoyens
je crois de manière très forte
alors vous m'interrogez sur qui peut
porter à ces éléments là moi je vais
vous raconter hier et entre 10 et 15e
personne à paris pour le premier meeting
emmanuel macron verra personne qui
sortira de la primaire
j'allais dire de la belle alliance
populaire socialiste
il est clair que ceux qui pensent que
notre pays doit s'engager encore plus
résolument dans le progrès marquer aussi
l'europe par ces idées là c'est à dire
effectivement je suis pas aujourd'hui
très favorable à la politique telle
qu'elle est menée au niveau européen
je pense qu'il faut la changer mais
c'est plutôt aujourd'hui les valeurs de
notre ami qui représente françois fillon
qui sont en tête real neuf aujourd'hui
au niveau européen moi je souhaite une
europe beaucoup plus combative et une
europe beaucoup plus efficace et
volontariste je le dis peut-être que tel
que je le pense en tout cas par contre
je souhaite une europe
ça c'est sûr et donc si manuel valls or
en tête de la primaire est bien faudra
qu'il y ait une entente entre manuel
valls et et emmanuel macron on pourra
pas avoir sur ces thèmes qui sont des
thèmes exigeant qui doivent mobiliser
nos citoyens avoir de candidat pas gagné
d'avancé
si ça n'est pas le cas si ça n'est pas
le cas moi je suis assez ravi qu'il y
ait un candidat en dehors de la logique
de la primaire et il faudra le moment
venu ankama nous vendre toutes ses
responsabilités manuel macro tout à fait
valérie grandet on part les programmes
et les points sur lesquels ça laisse
jouer
la réforme de la sécu c'est quelque
chose qui a beaucoup cristallisé autour
de la droite
si je vous dis qu'il ya certains élus de
droite actuellement qui s'inquiète pour
la suite de la campagne de ce que ce
projet peut créer
et ce en quoi il peut être négatif pour
la suite de la campagne de la droite
ceux qui ceux qui s'inquiètent c'est
parce qu'ils ont mal lu le programme de
françois fillon sur cette partie santé
évidemment puisque en fait françois
fillon a fait ce diagnostic que tous les
français peuvent mesurer c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une vitesse il ya
une santé à deux vitesses
on sait très bien que quand on a la
chance de pouvoir se payer une bonne
mutuelle et bien on est bien remboursés
au niveau de ses frais d'optique ou de
ces frais dentaires etc aujourd'hui en
l'état la sécurité sociale rembourse mal
les français les plus démunis
sur ces deux points là par exemple donc
françois fillon ce qu'il veut au niveau
de la santé ait eu notamment au niveau
de la sécurité sociale c'est évidemment
ne pas déremboursés ou casser
complètement système auquel il est
absolument attaché mais c'est justement
qu'ils aient une vraiment une inéquité
envers tous les français les plus
pauvres les classes modestes et aussi
ceux qui ont du coup plus d'argent pour
se payer des soins et que justement ces
gens et un les gens les plus modestes et
un panier de franchise de soins auxquels
ils pourront se pourrit coûts pourront
continuer à se faire soigner
correctement au delà il va falloir
passer des électeurs de droite aux
électeurs français
oui et ça va être l'enjeu des prochains
mois écoutez c'est ce qu'on a fait déjà
depuis de longs mois pendant cette
campagne des primaires où on a été
expliqué aux français
et la preuve c'est que le score sans
appel que françois fillon a fait et au
premier tour et au second tour avec 67%
des gens qui se sont déplacés qui ont
qui ont adhéré à ces propositions qui ne
sont pas des promesses et des
propositions qu'il a construite avec les
français je pense que c'est le c'est là
dessus qu'on va pouvoir s'appuyer pour
aller convaincre de plus en plus de
français et expliquer ce programme de
réformes de notre pays ça fait doucement
rigoler en fait d'écouter ça mettait son
c'est la vieille politique qui se
recycle en permanence
est ce que c'est la doublure bat déjà
marine le pen elle sa campagne elle va
pas virer à droite va pas virer à gauche
elle
elle tend à rassembler les français
voilà c'est la campagne de la force de
la cohérence et de l' équilibre au final
monsieur fillon la même affaire à bras
gauche pardonnez-moi mais entre elles et
marion maréchal-le pen
premièrement il n'ya pas d'extrême
droite tchèques un parti patriote voilà
démocratique citoyen républicain qui
point final le front national n'est pas
un parti d'extrême droite
dixit le ministre de l'intérieur ne vous
en déplaise ensuite on n'y est pas
encore ensuite ce que julien schick
marine le pen elle a présenté sa
candidature au nom du peuple ce qui fait
la grande différence puisque je le
disait françois fillon s'est présenté au
nom du medef ou non des notables oh non
finalement des des riches puisque on
remarque que l'électorat de françois
fillon sont plutôt les notables âgées de
province 4 millions et non pas 40
millions d'électeurs français et que
manuel valls lui s'est présenté au nom
des pseudos diversité au nom du vivre
ensemble au nom de l'ouverture au monde
et tout ça toute cette politique
finalement qui a mis la france au fonds
depuis des années vous êtes allergique
cesser la pratique et sécurité de vos
bilans respectifs donc il faut changer
vous parliez une idée nouvelle
il faut un renouvellement total il faut
changer ce système donc qui a mis la
france dans le déclin ce stade mazet
système au niveau
je suis désolé les idées que propose
marine le pen aujourd'hui sont
exactement les mêmes que celles
économiquement parlant que celle de
monsieur fillon de monsieur valls du
tout elle ne veut pas augmenter les
salaires et le redis elle ne veut pas
garantir les 35 heures et le redis au
final vous voulez sortir de leur
garantir et 35 heures ah non pas du tout
c'est déjà le programme de marine le pen
n'est pas encore sorti en février verra
encore c'est ça le final programme et
nous on y travaille concrètement avec
les français sinon mais n'ont pas qu'une
petite caste de technocrates et on
reçoit pas nos ordres de bruxelles et
millions français c'est pas la vérité
malheureusement c'est l'année et noté
monsieur
qui dit être le candidat de la vérité
devrait plutôt dire aux français la
réalité
oui courage de la vérité on est contre
le laxisme et la complaisance de
monsieur fillon vis-à-vis du
communautarisme notamment sa fin puisque
m'isoler florine jean luc mélenchon il
va porter quoi on a un peu fait le tour
de tout le monde donc c'est à vous de
nous le dire dans cette campagne sur sur
quel thème contre l'europe
bien sûr contre contre l'europe et j'en
passe en même temps les traités
européens actuels c'est clairement un
obstacle avoir une politique réellement
souveraine une réunion politique
réellement social aujourd'hui tout ce
qu'on propose c'est de sortir de ces
traités européens là c'est ça c'est ça
la base aujourd'hui mais la base est là
elle est également dans le fait que les
citoyens doivent se réapproprier aussi
la chose publique
dire que comme je disais tout à l'heure
les citoyens doivent pouvoir créer eux
mêmes une sixième république qui
répondent à leurs aspirations et c'est
ça que nous propose dès le lendemain
d'élection on convoque une assemblée
constituante
ensuite on organise le partage des
richesses parce qu'aujourd'hui les
salaires sont bas et pensions sont
basses ça on n'en peut plus et la
troisième chose c'est également la
planification écologique il faut
impérativement qu'on prenne la mesure du
danger qui a aujourd'hui une première
force ennemie écologie mais oui mais
personne n'en parle monsieur fillon n'en
a jamais parlé madame le pen on attend
toujours qu'elle en parle d'un collectif
nouvelle écologie on aborde des
propositions tout à fait pragmatique
vous la partie j'ai peut-être mais
monsieur van sant en tout cas où
monsieur macro eux n'en parlait jamais
avoir de bonnes idées d'ailleurs on se
rejoint il a copié le programme de
madame le pen sur sur la politique de la
mer notamment mais c'est à dire c'est
que nous étions les premiers à organiser
les premières assises de la mer c'était
nous sommes tous les faux c'est faux
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que vous
n'allez pas au bout c'est dire que vous
voulez sortir de l'union européenne
d'accord mais ensuite vous êtes pour
l'ouverture au moins vous êtes pour
l'ouverture des frontières voulait pas
pour la protection des travailleurs
français
nous sommes protectionnisme et contre
les contre la directive d'être compte
des travailleurs détachés à l'union
européenne à l'union européenne vous
votez toutes les directives de
libéralisation mais vous êtes pour
l'accueil la directive sur les secrets
de nos communes
la directive sur le secret des affaires
madame le pen a voté pour te dire que
demain un journaliste qui veut enquêter
sur les sur les finances d'une
entreprise qui serait pas forcément on a
vu par exemple avec les panama peppers
derniers temps vous avez voté pour que
ce journaliste ce soit condamné et que
l'entreprise puisse tranquillement aller
mettre son argent dans un paradis fiscal
vous votez pour ça et ça c'est les
directives de libéralisation au final
vous êtes pour le grand patronat vous le
montrez vous êtes exactement en accord
avec moi et si marine le pen il est avec
le grand patronat dire c'est qu'en fait
françois fillon il a travaillé tous les
sujets tous les sujets avec des gens qui
sont engagés dans ces sujets là si on
prend l'environnement et ben moi je vous
invite à aller voir son programme il a
trouvé la page on à 58 m pour vous c'est
pour les français
si vous avez rien c'est toujours très
réducteur la droite conservatrice la
santé la famille
oh oui maintenant la droite la droite
elle s'intéresse à tous les sujets qui
préoccupent les français
et moi je vois en tant que mère de
famille oui je suis intéressé par
l'écologie j'espère qu'on va pouvoir que
mes enfants pourront continuer à vivre
dans un peu plus la très près par la
droite grandbaie.mu l'environnement et
dans les débats télévisés en fait n'ont
jamais été abordé ces sujets là par les
journalistes off
mais bien sûr été conduits en effet on a
qu'on a pas pu il n'y a quasiment pas de
discours sur les colos sur les côtés
intéressé particulièrement l'électorat
la primaire droite mais si les gens dans
les meeting de françois fillon
l'environnement à l'écologie était très
très soul reste 2 minutes 30 presque
rien donc on arrive à la fin de cette
émission dites-nous rapidement au cas où
votre représentants d'autres partis
n'est pas comment vous envisagez un
deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle si voilà tony rebeyrotte
si la gauche n'y est pas je voulais dire
un mot sur les mutations j'en ai parlé
tout à l'heure et notamment la nouvelle
économie celle de l'environnement celle
de l'écologie c'est un élément clé des
futurs mutation mais ça je vais dire il
ya un laps de temps peut-être
il ya un large consensus pour votre vous
une bourre j'allais dire avancèrent ce
cadre d'accord sur la question
simplement s'y est pas voilà si la
gauche n'est pas au deuxième tour de la
présidentielle moi j'envisage pas
aujourd'hui cette hypothèse je vais vous
dire pourquoi parce que je pense contre
la droite réactionnaire extrême droite
et entre j'allais dire les idées alors
que j'appelle souvent de de montaut show
mêlant bourg puisque pour moi ça fait un
peu la même chose vous les voyez ce que
me disent d'ailleurs on aime on est sur
la même conception extrême gauche issu
des bâches conséquent entre entre les
deuxièmes places qui sert les liens
l'âme du village service est ouverte et
donc je pense qu'il peut dire merci à
françois fillon peut y avoir
j'allais dire au centre droit des
personnes qui sont sur ces légendes
d'affronter les médias
mais il peut raisonner pour centre
gauche et d'une manière assez loin à
gauche des personnes qui jouent en
france parce qu'on restait les
tremblements une scie deuxième tour de
la présidentielle
en quelques mots jean luc mélenchon peut
y être allé que le rassemblement de la
gauche je sais pas ça qui intéresse les
gens aujourd'hui la gauche ne veut plus
rien dire aujourd'hui la question est là
le clivage est entre ceux qui défendent
l'intérêt général et ceux qui défendent
les intérêts particuliers nous défendre
l'intérêt général et c'est pour ça qu'on
sera au second tour de programme il est
cohérent généraux 12 vous vous êtes sûrs
d'y être on n'est jamais sûr mais je ne
l'envisagent pas marine le pen va gagner
cette élection il va remettre la france
en ordre pour les cinq ans à venir
vous aurez peut-être besoin d'autres
gens pour battre le front national c'est
écouter en tout cas il ya toujours une
grande famille à droite qui fait partie
la droite républicaine avec on aura
besoin évidemment des gens au centre
pour pour cette élection mais par contre
une chose est sûre c'est que françois
fillon garde le cap
il ne fait aucun compromis il a une
ligne de conduite est là dessus les
français ont
ont déjà fait une première étape est
terminée
merci à tous les quatre d'être venus
débattre c'était très intéressant on se
retrouve en début d'année prochaine avec
une émission spéciale sur la région
bourgogne franche comté un an après
l'élection de marie-guite dufay
bon dimanche au revoir et merci
[Musique]